yeah so we've heard a lot this morning
and um and more generally in the
workshop about
network formation models
and um i think all of them so far have
been stochastic in nature they're
probabilistic models that generate
networks according to some probability
distribution
and you know my um quick and very
subjective take of the very large
literature on this topic is that um such
models you know are powerful for a
number of reasons first of all you know
you can do statistics on them you can do
inference on them etc and it does seem
empirically from a research perspective
that one can
find satisfyingly simple probabilistic
models for network formation that give
rise to
structural properties that we frequently
observe in actual network data so you
know the canonical example being we see
heavy tail degree distributions all the
time and preferential attachment is sort
of this appealing simple probabilistic
model that generates that property so
there's sort of there's there's success
on that front
um
much much smaller and much less known is
the literature on network formation
games um which you know i've worked a
bit in matt has worked quite a bit in
and a few others
and um the motivation for network
formation games is the observation that
despite the sort of appeal of these
stochastic models that in the end
certainly if you're talking about social
networks nobody really believes that
people flip coins to decide who to
connect to
in social structures
rather it seems more accurate to say
that you know people are agents with
free will and motivation and interests
and they join networks or form links
because you know even though it takes
efforts to do that in some sense they
get utility they get some kind of
benefit out of joining a network or at
least forming these relationships
so you know if you start taking this
line of thought to its logical extreme
you get to gain theory and and to the to
the literature on network formation
games
um where
you know you essentially posit that
agents have a utility function in which
there's some cost to them to form links
to other agents
but upon doing so they join a
macroscopic network formed by all of the
agents
that gives them some individual benefit
okay so um to give perhaps the the
standard simple example the simplest
network formation game or type of game
would be one in which you can form links
to other individuals in the population
at some cost per link
um so that's sort of the negative part
of your utility but then when you join
the resulting network formed by all of
the links gives you some benefit and it
might be a benefit that let's say
depends abstractly on your position in
the network so your overall utility
might be the negative of your edge
expenditures
and and then also minus the sum of your
shortest path distance to all the other
parties in the network so you know you
don't want to spend too much on edges
but you want to be in the middle of the
network where everybody's very close to
you okay
and i've worked a little bit in this
literature i find it very interesting um
it's much less success you know so the
good thing about it is i think there's
something real about it i think that
it's uh
you know it's closer to talk in the
language of utility theory and and
microeconomics
um about people's motivations than it is
to imagine them you know truly making
random decisions about how they they
form links in the network
empirically though um it seems quite
difficult to find simple network
formation games which give rise to
natural looking network structures so
the the running joke which i think i've
discussed with ashish and his colleagues
before is that if you ask like what is
the equilibrium of your typical network
formation game well depending on you
know the edge cost it's either the empty
network it's the star or it's the
complete network and this is kind of all
you can get okay
so that that's you know
so i think there's a lot still to say
there and it's early for the field um
but
that you know sort of deficit of the
theory doesn't prevent one from trying
experiments on human subjects and seeing
what's happened what happens and so
that's what i'm going to describe here
so i'm going to describe to you
behavioral experiments on a network
formation game
this was done in the context of a series
of human subject experiments that we've
been doing at penn in which we bring
groups of about three dozen human
subjects into a lab at a time and have
them play
games with each other for real
compensation um so these are essentially
a sort of a behavioral instance of of of
you know behavioral game theory or
economics um
over a network structure okay so they're
trying to
perform some
collective possibly competitive tasks on
a network
um and
uh
throughout the vast majority of this
series of experiments those networks
were exogenously imposed on the subjects
and i'm going to tell you about the one
set of experiments we did where part of
the game itself was forming a network
and unlike the example i gave you where
the utility function said well you're
going to pay something for edges and
then you get some benefit based
abstractly on your network position
here we have a network formation game
where the the purpose of building the
network is in order to solve some
collective task okay and you'll see what
i mean by that as we go
um so let me first just quickly describe
to you the predecessor experiments that
that
that we did
because it'll tell you what task the
subjects are trying to solve
so what i want you to imagine is an
experiment or a series of experiments
maybe a couple of minutes each in which
every subject sees their local view of
some larger network
of 36 subjects
and in the initial experiments these
networks were exogenously chosen by us
as experimenters and and imposed on the
subjects and i'll show you what the
networks look like in a second
but the the task in question here the
game is what's called biased voting so
i'm going to show you sort of describe
it via this screenshot so this is what
the the gui looked like for these
particular experiments
you are a subject whose vertex is
clearly identified in the middle by this
this word you so in in all these
experiments you would see yourself in
the middle
and we're showing you um connections to
all of your edges who are other subjects
in the experiments and we are also in
this particular
experiment showing you the edges between
your neighbors okay so this is what
sometimes called your ego network you
know who your connect your friends are
you know which pairs of your friends are
connected with each other and which are
not and you don't know anything else
about the network structure okay
and
you can think of these experiments as a
simple coordination game with a
strategic twist if you're familiar with
the two-player game battle of the sexes
this is like a networked version of
battle of the sexes
so
here's here's how the payoffs work
the subjects have two minutes all
everybody has to do at each one of the
experiment is pick a color for their
vertex red or blue you can change your
color as many times as you want ace it's
a synchronous move
and so if you were a subject in the
experiments you know you can change this
from red to blue and back as many times
as you want and as your neighbors change
their color you would see that updated
on this interface okay
and
the payoffs go as follows if within the
two minutes allowed for each experiment
at some point in the two minutes
all 36 players are unanimously selecting
blue or all 36 are unanimously selecting
red then everybody will be paid
something and i'll come back to what the
something is in a second okay if that
condition doesn't hold everybody gets
absolutely nothing okay so if 35 of us
settle on red and only one of us is
holding out for blue everybody in the
room gets nothing okay so there is a
very very strong incentive towards
unanimity towards coordinating on one
color or the other okay
the strategic twist though is the
different subjects in the same
experiment prefer convergence to one
color over the other so in this
particular screenshot this player is
being told if we reach unanimity to blue
you will be paid a dollar 25 and if we
reach unanimity to red you will be paid
75 cents
and a shish might be in the same
experiment and have the opposite
incentives or or or you might even not
be symmetric payoffs okay
so
the point is is we all to get any payoff
we have to reach unanimity but we care
about what color we reach unanimously to
and there's a there's a strategic
tension yes um can you say a little bit
about
what they believe about the graph
they're embedded in they know nothing
about it and did you elicit anything
along those lines or you mean did we ask
them what did you
what are they imagined
i mean um
i don't know what they're imagining it's
in the context of an undergraduate class
on network science
so they you know they're familiar with
the language of networks they've perhaps
been exposed to preferential attachment
and network formation games generally
so they're not total civilians but we
haven't primed them in any way about
what the network structures would look
like okay
michael along those lines yeah um so the
individual sort of first person
perspective here they have so many
neighbors of course all their neighbors
could be blue and they could be blue
there still could be a red person out
there that they can't see that's correct
that's right are they
are they notified there's a red person
out there no all but they do know that
if at any point in you know in any point
in the experiment there's a unanimous
choice the system will freeze and
everybody's payoffs will be lost so
basically as long as it's going on you
know there's not unanimity and that's
that's all you would know other than
what additionally you prefer by infer
from your network's neighborhood okay
okay so everybody understand the um the
setup here okay um
and so by the way these i won't go into
exactly why but you might if some of you
that remember it might be able to
remember um we we were sub we were
loosely inspired in these experiments by
the um
2008 democratic primary between hillary
clinton clinton and barack obama
but but so basically in order for any of
us to get payoff one side or the other
one type by which i mean whether you
have a higher payoff for red or a higher
playoff payoff for blue one one side or
the other has to acquiesce and accept
their lower payoff okay and so if you're
designing an experiment like this and
and you're picking the networks that the
subjects are going to play over as we
did in the first experiment so i'm going
to very briefly describe to you
the interesting you know choices are
well what network structures and also
how do i arrange the two types of
players red preferring versus blue
preferring within the network okay and
again because it's not the focus of this
particular presentation i don't want to
say a lot about it but this is basically
showing you samples of the types of
networks we gave them
these are all in pairs so this network
is exactly the same as this network and
i'm just showing you two different
layouts one of which highlights the
separation between the two types and the
other one is the more standard layout
which tries to generate things with high
degree towards the middle and lower
degree vertices at the periphery but you
know these are all networks over here in
which we've divided the population into
two equal sized populations of red and
blue
and then you can play around with the
inter versus intra group connectivity so
you can kind of create clustered models
where you have a red cluster and a blue
cluster and most of the edges go within
the clusters
and then of course you can also do the
opposite
where most players
have edges that go to the other cluster
and you know you can actually create
such a network that easily makes
everyone perceive as if they're in the
minority even though of course
there's an equal number of participants
of both types
of course they would only have to
perceive that through the color choices
of their neighbors which might be
changing as they try to reach
convergence to one color versus the
other but one comment i will make is
that in all these experiments it is a
ritual fact that at the very first
seconds of the experiment everybody
enters choosing their higher payoff
color okay
um
so so you do you know i think people did
get some very very
good sense of at least the color choices
that the preferences of their neighbors
in the early seconds of the experiment
okay
and then these are all networks in which
there's um a very large majority for red
let's say in this one there's 30 that
prefer red and only six that prefer blue
um but they the networks were generated
according to preferential attachment and
the
small minority that prefers red are the
highest degree vertices okay so you can
view these experiments
as a test of whether a small but well
connected minority can systematically
imposed their preference
on on the majority a grant against the
greater social welfare right because the
mass social welfare solution here would
be everybody playing blue so that the
highest number of players get their
preferred choice okay so you can you
know so this is sort of the perverse
little kinds of things we've been doing
to to pin undergraduates for the last
six or seven years or so
and
um again i want to quickly get on to the
network formation version of this task
um
but but you know the bottom line is this
is a fairly challenging task and we're
deliberately choosing networks which are
highlighting this tension between the
two sides right um
and and subjects do well at this task
right so in the 81 experiments that we
gave them you know they didn't take
anything i guess we only allowed a
minute not two minutes but um they they
you know converged on on the vast
majority of experiments to unanimity to
one color the other
interesting side comment the success
rate was much much higher on these
minority power experiments where of the
27 that we did
were of that form 24 of them actually
reached unanimity always to the minority
preference
um
okay
so this was the this is the task um and
um
you know
it it had always bothered me in this
line of experimentation that we
um
you know there are many many artificial
things about these experiments okay
these are highly stylized experiments
you know we're taking real human beings
and kind of forcing them into these
settings where they can only exhibit
kind of insect-like um behavior um so
there are many there are many there are
many um things that are artificial about
the experiments but the one that always
bothered me the most was this fact that
we were exogenously picking the network
structures and imposing them on the
subjects because after all you know real
networks sort of don't don't form that
way and you can of course do all kinds
of interesting things in the lab that
way like these minority power
experiments but i always sort of thought
like well it would be more interesting
if building the network was part of the
task itself that you sort of need to
build the network in service of the
problem you're being asked to solve and
you know men there's this sort of small
strand of literature in organizational
behavior in other areas that that
basically suggests that that that's what
people you know that people perform
better as groups if you let them build
their own networks and that they'll
sometimes even you know circumvent
whatever network you try to impose on
them in order to make the organization
work more efficiently so you know
um
there was a period back in the dot-com
boom where um you know consulting firms
like mckenzie were making a fortune
going around to organizations and saying
like well you know here's the org chart
you showed me and here's how people
really interact in your organization and
work gets done and you know invariably
in malcolm gladwell like fashion there's
some low-level you know secretary in the
in the organization who's you know
infinitely more important than the ceo
this this kind of you know um this sort
of story so i was sort of interested in
in you know whether that's true or not
whether letting people
build the network um knowing what the
task was was a helpful thing or not um
and i kind of suspected it would be and
i wanted to test it and so i decided
well let's test it in the context of
this this biased voting game
what did i do there
okay so
so we did a later set of experiments on
admittedly a different set of subjects
because it was a couple of years later
and so you're seeing a very similar
interface here
um but in this in in now in this game
the the building of the network itself
is part of the task so what i mean by
that is that at the beginning of each
little one minute experiment
the network consisted of 36 isolates 36
vertices with no connections to any
other human subject okay
and then as per the interface here
anybody who wants to at any time in the
experiment can purchase an edge
for in this case three cents okay and
your edge purchases would be deducted
from any earnings that you made in the
experiment so if you for instance as it
says in this experiment would be paid
three dollars for reaching unanimity to
red and you in fact if the population
did reach unanimity to red you would be
paid three dollars minus your edge
expenditures if unanimity wasn't reached
in an experiment in the in these
versions of the experiments all edge
expenditures were forgiven so you
couldn't i'm actually not even sure that
irb
um uh approval would allow you know
subjects to have it have to pay me after
participating in an experiment so so you
know if they didn't if they didn't solve
the problem nobody had to pay anything
for the edges but in the case that you
you did you would you would have to have
it deducted yeah that's a design choice
question
from this um
yeah so like we we know our preferences
and then if you're blue and i'm red like
we're playing this adversarial game of
trying to get the upper hand by forming
the graph possibly in real time
did you do a version of this where i
didn't know
my preferences like i know i'm going to
interact in the community i don't know
if i'm going to have preferences for red
or blue and what the haven't tried that
haven't tried that and remember you only
know the preferences of other parties
from whatever you can glean through
their color choices i see so this is i'm
i think so types are unknown the only
the only thing you can observe is
behavior you don't really know
and you might infer behavior by by
noting that this person played red at
the beginning
and you know but you don't know for sure
you know maybe maybe they maybe they
were acquiescing yeah the conservation
of links so
then
no no okay so um so and furthermore um
edges are bilateral so if i buy an edge
to you i pay for it but you get the
benefit of it in that you can now see
what i'm doing too so just go so let me
just go a little bit further here so at
the beginning of the experiment right
you would see you in the middle here
with no connections whatsoever okay
and then as the experiment
progresses and you buy edges and other
by edges the the the interface part of
this was difficult to design but so you
would have a dynamic layout and what
would happen is if you add if you added
a new edge and i haven't yet said how
you choose who you add an edge to too
what would happen is a new you know sort
of a new vertex would appear in sort of
the periphery of your diagram with a
link to you and then there would be kind
of a um you know kind of a tension model
readjustment of the layout to show you
what your new neighborhood looked like
okay
okay we also made sure
that the number of edges you were
allowed to buy
um
made it so that you couldn't actually
ever have zero payoff for your less
preferred color okay we didn't want
subjects to get to a point where their
edge expenditures caused let's say their
post expenditure payoff for blue to
actually be zero because at that point
you know
rationally you should be infinitely
stubborn and just hold out for your
higher color because you're indifferent
so the number of edges you could
purchase and we played around with the
edge cost too but whatever the edge cost
was we made sure that you had a non-zero
payoff even for your less preferred
color post expenditures okay
okay now of course the crucial design
question here to which i don't claim
that this is the right answer out of
many many that you could imagine is if
you say i want to add another i want to
buy another link
you know what information if any should
you have about what the destination of
that link is because you don't have
individual identity of the other
of the other subjects in the room right
and you know we could give meaningless
labels and you could say well link me to
vertex 17 but that doesn't seem very
satisfying the system could just decide
random to pick a random but then that
would seem to bake in kind of an heirish
regi-like structure so we wanted to give
a design that seemed to provide some
simple information that might be useful
for the task in question okay so
basically
what you that that's what's going on in
this new element of the interface down
here so
all of the people that are currently
your neighbors are represented in the
central part of the diagram
every vertex that's that you are that is
not a neighbor of you is represented by
a circle down in this grid over here
and that circle is telling you what the
current degree of that vertex is and
what their current shortest path
distance to you is okay and if there's a
if you know so here for instance is a is
a vertex you're not connected to that's
three hops away from you and happens to
have degree three also
and a star inside means there's just
more than one vertex with those those
that pair of values okay
so if you want to buy a new edge you
come over here and click and say like
well
you know maybe what i want i might say
like well i want to click on this vertex
because they have a very high degree and
maybe they're aggregating information
elsewhere in the network that would be
useful for me to see
or maybe i want to click on a low degree
vertex because i'll be able to influence
them more so i might buy edges imagining
that i'll gain information i might buy
edges because i want to influence and i
might use the distance information to
decide you know whether i want to see
things closer or further from my own
current neighborhood yes
those are the degrees
these yes that's right these are the
degrees so so we're also telling you
what the current degrees of your
neighbors are so this
by the way this is sort of our model for
the maximum you might be reasonably
expected to know about your social
network who your friends are which pairs
of them are friends with each other and
maybe some crude information about which
of your friends are relatively more or
less popular so to speak
okay but it's interesting that you don't
know the blue or red state of the people
um
you mean over here yeah that would give
you global information right we we
wanted to preserve the locality of
information about about color choices
and decisions
and then we wanted to give you some
crude topological information about
vertices you're not connected to
otherwise you'd have otherwise in some
sense if you put colors over here
everybody would have a global view and
it the network aspect of it really goes
away okay
okay let me
trundle forward here okay so i think i
said most of this so i mean this is a
very complicated game right i mean it is
a asynchronous move multi-stage game of
partial information even analyzing
watered-down versions of this
theoretically it seems like a hopeless
task to me
but you can sort of identify what the
strategic tensions are in bench
purchases i mean i mean first of all at
a minimum it would seem to collectively
we would need to purchase a spanning
tree in order to be able to solve this
problem because otherwise if we have you
know two disconnected components the
chance of being able to unanimously
coordinate seems low okay
so there's a sort of a minimum density
we need of course every one of us would
prefer that everybody else purchased
that spanning tree and we get to use it
for free
um so you know one question is should i
buy edges or not would i buy it for
information or influence should i do it
early in the game or late in the game to
hire low degree players near or far
okay
so what happened um so
running short on time basically they did
terribly at this time
all of the experiments that we did over
six years on many many different tasks
including biased voting where we were
giving them exogenously chosen networks
often
perversely chosen to be what we
perceived to be difficult for the task
in question
this was by far and away the lowest
success rate so
one measure of this that you can use to
just kind of measure collective
performance over all the experiments
tasks networks we've run over the years
is sort of social welfare right i can
post talk i know every network i gave
the subjects i know what the incentives
were and i can compute for every little
experiment i've ever done
what would have been the max social
welfare solution what would have been
the configuration of play by the
subjects which would have cost me the
most in subject payments and i can sum
all those up put it in the denominator
and in the numerator it can sum up all
of their actual payments that ratio
excluding these experiments is close to
90
so of everything we've ever tried
they've left
just a little bit more
than 10 of the available money on the
table
here their success rate was you know
depending on the session in question
either you know was below 50 and in some
cases as low as 38 percent and there's
additional details i'm not giving you
here including in some of the networks
rather than starting off with the empty
network we started with a seed network
which gave them some basic structure for
free and then they could additionally
add edges to that structure but in the
interest of time let me not go into that
and say you know they didn't do well at
this task they did much much more poorly
than anything we'd given them so we kind
of you know for the first time allowed
them to control the structure of the
network they understood the task well
and we allowed them to control the
structure of the network within the
confines of the interface and
information that i described to you and
try to build a network in service of the
of performing the task well and not only
did they do terribly relative to
everything we've tried before they did
terribly relative to the same task on
networks that we gave them um
exogenously okay so you know i was
surprised at this outcome i found this
kind of disturbing and at odds with what
i expected and there's at least two
there's at least two plausible
explanations or hypotheses for why they
did that one is what i would call
overload and the other one is what i
would call stubbornness overload is just
like well maybe they can build good
networks for this task but in one minute
having to build the network
simultaneously while you're trying to
solve this coordination task maybe it's
just too much to do in too short a time
and if we'd given them longer or let
them build the network first and then
try to solve the problem on that network
after maybe it would have been better
the other one is what i would call
stubbornness
maybe
maybe they built perfectly good networks
for solving the task but post the
incentives the players who'd spent the
most on edge purchases and therefore had
reduced their lower payoff to a low
level
maybe they were just you know um i'm
holding out for my higher color and it
changes their behavior right because
their incentives have been modified by
the network then you could easily
imagine yourself think sitting there
thinking like well you know i bought a
lot of edges my lower payoff is pretty
low now so i don't mind walking away
from that and furthermore i deserve my
higher payoff because i built all this
infrastructure that we're using to
coordinate on is there a question yeah
um
what was the number
like were there a lot of
players buying
edges i'll come i'll come back to
exactly that
in just a second okay
so
have the um students who are building
the networks have they previously played
the game with the freak with a
given network no
no this is a fresh batch of subjects
however your question is a nice segue to
a third session that we ran
on a fresh set of human subjects that
tried to test whether either of these
two hypotheses were true about overload
or stubbornness
so this is sort of a schematic of this
third session design so in the first two
sessions actually um
you know the picture is you start off
with no edges everybody's an isolate and
the the colors here are sort of showing
you the relative payoffs for the two
colors so this is a player that gets a
higher payoff for blue this is a player
that gets a higher payoff for red this
is not data this is just a schematic
okay so then they play the game and they
build the network maybe they do or maybe
they don't reach unanimity but now you
have some network structure and now the
incentives have been changed right the
relative these are sort of showing
relative payoffs right so now
everybody's incentives are changed and
so here's a player for instance who
bought a lot on for a lot of edges so
their pay their relative payout for blue
is now very tiny compared to their
payoff for red okay
so to test the
um to test the overload hypothesis
what we can do is we can now take this
network as a fixed exogenous network and
give it to a fresh set of subjects
just like in the original bias voting
experiments but now this is we're going
to give them networks created by human
subjects okay but that network may or
may not have led to a successful outcome
from 40 of the time right um so those
are successful so we generally did what
i'm about to describe to you using the
networks that were hardest for the
subjects and on which they failed in
these earlier sessions okay so if i want
to test the overload hypothesis you know
i can take a network built by the
subjects in the sessions i've described
to you so far and i can now restore the
original incentives onto this built
network okay and so now this is just
like the original biased voting
experiments it just happens to be on a
network generated by a prior set of
human subjects okay
if i want to test the overload
hypothesis right i can just take this
actual configuration down here as my
exogenous network
preserving the post play incentives of
the earlier group so everybody get
what's going on right so if it's the
case that they in other words if it's
the case that they were building good
networks for the task but they just
couldn't solve it because of the
overload problem then subjects should do
well
the new subject should do well in this
configuration and if they were building
good networks here but the problem was
just that people like this have now
become very stubborn and made it hard to
reach unanimity then subjects should do
well over here yeah i know amount of
time
anyway and if you don't go through your
slides people are going to ask you
questions okay
all right so um
but i won't be too much longer okay so
everybody understand the setup so this
is what we did in this third session in
this third session there's no network
formation element at all it's just like
back in these original experiments and
just they just don't know that the
networks they happen to be playing on
rather than being generated according to
preferential attachment have it happened
to have been generated according to a
previous set of human subjects okay
um so
the answer is they did even worse
okay
so now the subjects don't have anything
to worry about except reaching
coordination and reaching unanimity in
this coordination game and in this final
session basically you know we went down
to about 41
success rate okay um down from a little
bit below 50 to now down by four so
it it seems that
the conclusion
is that you know we gave human subjects
the ability to control the structure of
their network within some reasonable
parameters and sort of information view
in service of a particular task and
letting them build the network by
letting them build the network they
proceeded to build networks lousy for
solving the task on which solving this
coordination problem seems to be
difficult even for a fresh set of
subjects that have nothing to worry
about other than playing on the given
network okay
now you know you might ask why what is
it about these networks that was hard or
how these no you know or even just more
basically how did the networks
look similar or different to the
naturally occurring networks um you know
so you can measure things like
clustering coefficient degree
distribution and
in the interest of time let me not say a
lot there but other than you know there
there do seem to be traces of these
commonly occurring properties in these
artificially built networks including
high clustering coefficients heavy tail
degree distributions but getting back to
your question you know what did the edge
purchases look like
so one telling fact is that there was a
large amount of free riding okay so a
very small fraction of the participants
purchased the vast majority of the edges
so these three curves are correspond to
different cost of edges right high
medium or low edge costs but what i'm
doing is i'm ordering
the subjects in a given experiment
or or across all the
experiments
by how many edge expenditures they made
so sort of from lowest to highest and
i'm saying what fraction of the total
edge expenditures were made by what
fraction of the population so you can
see at 50 of the population here um
we're down
at near or below 10 of the edges so
fully
half of the population is hardly buying
any of the edges at all and if you want
to get up to 50 percent of the edge
expenditures you need to take about 80
percent of the population or more
so there it does seem that that a very
small number of people have have done on
the bulk of the edge purchasing on
average and this of course is related to
having a a heavy tail degree
distribution
and um
and you might imagine how this influence
is played now we we spent some time
trying to look for you know figure out
what structural properties about the
networks they build seem to make this
coordination task hard by the way you
know there was no problem with
connectivity right even under the high
even under the high edge costs
experiments um there was it was the the
networks were always connected and and
and you know they were sparser you know
rationally they're sparser the more you
charge for edges but there was there was
enough connectivity there you definitely
had more than a spanning tree and you
had fairly cyclical graphs in fact here
and this is my last slide here is a
visualization of three actual networks
built by the subjects under
high edge costs right so um you know
they're relatively sparse networks but
you can see the preponderance of these
individuals with very high degree
who probably are also the ones who you
know it's unlikely that it happened to
be the case that everybody else
purchases edge to to them that would be
a bit difficult in the interface so
perhaps not all but many of the edges
that you see emanating from these hubs
were likely purchased by the hub itself
okay so you do have these heavy tail
degree distributions you know if you ask
well what's different about a network
like this then let's say a preferential
attachment network with a comparable
edge density um it's sort of the over
reliant it's not just the presence of
these connectors but an over reliance on
these these connectors so what what this
column is showing you is this same
network in each case
with the um with the highest degree
vertex deleted from the network just
deleting a single vertex okay and you
can see that in all these three networks
deleting just the single high degree
vertex immediately
breaks the shatters the network into
many many connected components including
a large number of isolates okay
so
you know it's hard to know behaviorally
in in hindsight what people were doing
but it does seem if you compare this to
other sort of natural structural models
like preferential attachment you know
this this wouldn't happen in a
preferential attachment network of the
same density of you would you know
eventually of course you would if you
remove this by the way is removing the
two highest degree nodes right so it
really seemed that population wise there
were
just for sort of communication purposes
there were many many parts of the
network or even individuals that really
only had one source of connectivity and
if you're counting on that individual to
do information aggregation you just may
be out of luck if they're stubborn okay
so let me stop there and we can maybe
just
continue into the panel
so uh